per una fortunata coincidenza
ho cominciato a lavorare come
giornalista il giorno prima
dell'elezione di barack obama alla
presidenza degli stati uniti nel 2008 in
quello che allora era un grande
quotidiano
io ero lì quella notte come l'ultimo
arrivato e cercava di dare una mano
senza sapere bene dove mettere le mani
ma il giornale chiude schiuse tutto alle
3 del mattino quando i risultati avevano
appena cominciato ad arrivare e ancora
quindi non si sapeva chi avrebbe vinto
le elezioni
il punto è che non si poteva aspettare
oltre perché se non si sarebbe fatto in
tempo a mandare il giornale in
tipografia stamparlo e poi distribuirlo
nelle edicole e quindi alle 3 del
mattino si chiuse con quello che c'era
essendo avanti
chiuse anche il sito internet quindi che
fino alla mattina dopo non avrebbe dato
la notizia avrebbe detto se obama ha
vinto le elezioni non chiudere un aveva
un giornale prima che arrivino i
risultati elettorali è sempre un gesto
abbastanza rischioso
questo è quello che capita nel 2004
quando un giornale decise di dare per il
vincitore john kerry su george bush un
po prima del tempo
fatto sta che comunque io ero erano le
tre del mattino io ero fuori dalla
relazione e volevo trovare un posto in
cui continuare a seguire i risultati
volevo sapere come sarebbe andata a
finire
il problema è che aveva appena
cominciato a lavorare lì quindi non
avevo ancora una casa era ospitata dai
parenti che abitavano troppo lontano
perché potessi raggiungerli a quell'ora
reali dei miei amici nessuno era stato
fatto abbastanza da restare svegli tutta
la notte e quello che fare oggi
probabilmente tirar fuori dalla tasca il
mio smartphone collegarmi a internet
seguire i risultati così ma l'epoca di
smartphone erano questi così qui e
quindi non era semplicissimo utilizzarle
questo scopo
ero abbastanza disperata non sapevo cosa
fare
prova a cercare degli internet point
aperti tutta la notte ma non ne trovai
mi chiesi qual è l'unico posto che possa
trovare aperto tutta la notte è
provvisto di una connessione internet
gli alberghi allora raggiungersi la zona
della stazione ed entrai in quattro
cinque alberghi presentandomi dicendo
con una certa sfacciataggine che era un
giornalista devo collegarmi a internet a
tutti i costi la scena è anche
abbastanza ridicola descritta adesso
però erano comunque era sempre insomma
per le 3 del mattino passate e portiere
di notte negli alberghi e probabilmente
devono essere diciamo diffidenti per
contratto
quindi con piume l'educazione mi
respinsero tutti quanti mi viene in
mente a quel punto che per il primo
incarico al giornale di quel primo
giorno del mio primo incarico era stato
mandato a parlare con un gruppo di
americani e residente a roma che avrebbe
seguito quella notte risultati in un pub
che avevano riservato per sé e quindi
pensa proprio thunder e di prova in
bucarmi vediamo se mi fanno entrare e
passa attraverso della nottata con loro
una buona idea mi fecero entrare seguì
risultati con loro e fu anche se n'è
abbastanza felice allegra perché voi vi
ricordate come andò a finire
e fu anche l'inizio della mia piccola
carriera del giornalismo
io ho continuato a lavorare poi a roma
per altri due anni passando da un
giornale all'altro
finché nel 2010 non mi sono trasferito a
milano per lavorare alla fondazione di
un nuovo giornale soltanto online che si
sarebbe chiamato il post ora pensate che
l'idea di aprire un giornale in questo
momento è un'idea chi richiede una certa
dose di sventatezza perché un po come
diciamo se qualcuno volesse aprire
adesso un negozio di cd non è
esattamente l'investimento più più
proficuo e più sicuro per il periodo in
cui viviamo
i giornali di carta perdono copie anno
dopo anno e incassano sempre di meno
per farvi un'idea non serve che vi
sforzate di leggere i numeri ei nomi
questi sono gli incassi dei principali
gruppi editoriali italiani negli ultimi
quattro anni
tenete conto che la linea in alto e la
linea dello zero quindi avete presente
un po la situazione
i giornali online non hanno queste
difficoltà perché riescono a raggiungere
elettori che con molta più semplicità
con molta più facilità ma devono fare i
conti con la crisi economica le imprese
le aziende che in questi anni hanno
investiti in pubblicità sono state
sempre di meno e hanno investito sempre
di meno
la pubblicità online non permette di
incassare moltissimo e quindi i giornali
pur di tenersi a galla pur di
sopravvivere devono mettere insieme
quantità di lettori enormi e molto
difficile riuscirci è molto difficile
soprattutto se sei un giornale appena
nato
se non sei famoso se non ti conosce
nessuno questo fenomeno è quello che
viene definito crisi dei giornali dal
punto di vista proprio industriale ce
n'è un altro speculare e parallelo ma
diverso che è la crisi del giornalismo e
al c'è un'opinione diffusa anche tra i
giornalisti che secondo cui
la qualità del lavoro giornalistico
negli ultimi anni è peggiorata e non sia
e non sia di altissimo livello
di solito queste due crisi sono
utilizzate una come alibi dell'altra si
dice che i giornali sono fatti male
perché non hanno abbastanza soldi gli
altri rispondono i giornali non hanno
abbastanza soldi perché sono fatti male
non incassano abbastanza perché il
prodotto che offrono non è di grande
qualità
probabilmente sono entrambe le cose
queste cose si alimentano a vicenda ma
visto che anche se i giornali abbiamo
parlato anche le chiese del giornalismo
è un fenomeno che esiste davvero
ogni giorno sui quotidiani senza che
spesso ce ne rendiamo conto
vengono pubblicate moltissime notizie
imprecise scorrette
a volte anche apertamente false che non
hanno nessun tipo di legame con la
realtà non solo i giornali parlano una
lingua che che spesso una lingua
artificiosa incomprensibile per esempio
questi qui non è che hanno detto tutti
io virgola nell'inferno di anche perché
chi è che userebbe ma l'espressione del
genere parlando oralmente parlando con
qualcuno però sebbene abbiano insegnato
a scuola che le frasi che vengono messe
tra virgolette devono essere state
effettivamente pronunciate su giornali
italiani questa regola non vale
praticamente mai
ma a proposito della lingua si usano un
sacco di cliché a cui sono abituati
le formulazioni come e giallo è bufera
la bagarre sono dei cliché dei tic che
vengono usati in continuazione anche
quando creano degli effetti
involontariamente comici come questo poi
c'è un'altra cosa che nel gergo dei
giornalisti viene definito il boxino
morboso il borsino morboso sicurezza ce
l'avete presente e la colonna destra dei
quotidiani online e lo spazio in cui
potrete trovare ogni giorno la galleria
fotografica dei vip senza trucco la
soubrette che è scivolata in diretta
l'autogol filmato della settimana il
cane che abbaia ritmo di musica sono
contenuti che evidentemente non hanno
nessun valore giornalistico che sono
riprodotti identici su ogni giornale
anche giornali che vorrebbero avere
un'identità diversa tra loro
e quindi probabilmente nel lungo termine
sono contenuti che rovinano il brand del
giornale che che rovinano la promettono
la sua qualità
perché allora i giornali lo fanno lo
fanno perché questi contenuti permettono
di mettere insieme di raggiungere
moltissimi lettori non mi sentirete
quindi assolti da questo discorso
siccome fanno moltissimi click e i
giornali fanno fatica a stare a galla si
ricorre a contenuti come questo perché
sono delle scorciatoie ti permettono di
respirare un po nel breve termine anche
sapendo che questi che possono
compromettere la sopravvivenza sul lungo
termine
quando abbiamo fatto il nostro giornale
allora ci siamo detti come facciamo a
non finire schiacciati tra queste due
crisi tra le crisi dei giornali quella
del giornalismo come facciamo a non
dovessero essere costretti anche noi a
pubblicare il video del gattino del cane
che abbaia tempo di musica
abbiamo pensato che una soluzione
potesse essere imporci di alzare
moltissime l'asticella della qualità
offrire un per un prodotto che fosse il
migliore possibile non solo per il gusto
di farlo ma anche perché questo poteva
darci uno spazio sul mercato per
definire chi siamo e quindi permetterci
di stare in piedi prendendo affrontando
la crisi da un altro lato ci siamo dati
allora delle regole
benedini bene racconto 5 la prima regola
che ci siamo dati è cercare di essere
affidabili più possibile
noi diamo una notizia solo quando siamo
sicuri sicurissimi al cento per cento
verifichiamo una volta verifichiamo due
volte ci siamo detti che preferiamo
arrivare dopo gli altri giornali
prendendo un buco come si dice nel gergo
ma arrivare corretti
poi possiamo sbagliare ovviamente perché
non siamo dei mostri non siamo dei robot
però non vogliamo usare l'argomento
tutti possono sbagliare che diventa
anche un alibi giustifica qualsiasi
errore molti errori si possono evitare
se ci si impegna a farlo e noi cerchiamo
sempre di riuscirci la seconda regola
che ci siamo dati e parla come mangi e
quella cosa che vi raccontavo prima che
non vuol dire parla con sciatteria però
parlano la lingua delle persone non
erano inventarti una lingua diversa per
esempio scrivi o parla di terremoto solo
se c'è stato effettivamente un terremoto
e non usarla come una metafora per dire
per dire un'altra cosa
terza regola che ci siamo dati è stata
rivolgiti a tutte le persone
rivolgiti a tutti spiega bene tutto non
pensare
allora soltanto un pubblico di addetti
ai lavori di iniziati un grande
giornalista politico italiano negli anni
sessanta enzo forcella scrisse
provocatoriamente che ogni giornalista
poteva contare al massimo su 1500
lettori i membri del governo i
sottosegretari i suoi colleghi dirigenti
d'azienda anche del suo giornale vendeva
300.000 copie in realtà i veri
interlocutori erano quelli per quanto
sia passato molto tempo e forcella già
all'epoca lo diceva in modo provocatorio
ancora oggi un pezzo del giornalismo
italiano un pezzo rilevante
significativo continua a lavorare
immaginando di rivolgersi a queste
persone basta e quindi da moltissime
cose per scontato si aspetta che i
lettori di un giornale conoscono a
memoria tutte le puntate di tutte le
storie noi abbiamo pensato che fosse il
caso invece di spiegare tutto bene fin
dall'inizio ogni volta di anticipare le
domande del lettore di non dare per
scontato che i lettori potessero essere
come noi giornalisti sempre aggiornati
su qualsiasi cosa perché non è il loro
lavoro mentre invece il nostro e quindi
si è impegnati molto a spiegare tutto
sempre bene l'altra cosa che abbiamo
cercato di fare quarta regola cerca
valorizza e link a soprattutto i
contenuti migliori che sono prodotti
dagli altri giornali in libertà che si
fa ogni giorno ci siamo detti perché non
possiamo farlo anche noi
se c'è qualcuno che in grado di fare con
qualche altro giornale è in grado di
fare qualcosa meglio che possiamo farla
noi noi non lo capiamo non lo
scimmiottiamo e nemmeno ci giriamo
dall'altra parte ma lo segnaliamo lo
selezioniamo questa è una cosa che per
quanto possa offrirvi forse banale è una
novità radicale al francese
dell'approccio nel giornalismo in questo
momento storico questo è più o meno
un'immagine che riflette un po
l'approccio che le varie testate hanno
nei confronti dell'altra
ci sono giornali in cui c'è poco una
regola di non nominare negli articoli
figuriamoci linkare non nominare i
giornali avversari quando in realtà sia
i motori di ricerca sia il comportamento
stesso dei lettori e degli utenti e
dimostrano che questa questo approccio
molto più aperto
è un approccio che viene premiato un
approccio che ti permette di raggiungere
più lettori perché lettori che col tempo
riescono anche a fidarsi del tuo ruolo
di selezione dei contenuti di selezione
delle cose buone interessanti
arricchenti che si possono trovare in
giro
internet quinta regola che ci siamo dati
cercare di risparmiare il più possibile
sui costi
intanto è già affascinante che ve la
racconto io questa cosa perché di solito
i giornalisti non sono coinvolti nella
gestione finanziaria dei giornali si
pensa che il giornalista debba solo
scrivere l'articolo e basta noi invece
siamo corresponsabili dei conti del
giornale quindi ne sono a conoscenza noi
siamo sempre molto informati e quindi
innanzitutto abbiamo deciso di lavorare
molto banalmente e poi vorrei rinunciare
a tutta una serie di benefit di forse
anche di lussi che sono molto comune nei
giornali tradizionali non abbiamo ogni
mattina su ogni scrivania una pila di 15
giornali di carta per ciascuno perché
abbiamo gli abbonamenti pdf non abbiamo
abbonamenti e le agenzie di stampa
perché se sai usare twitter nel 2015 non
ti servono le grazie di stampa non
abbiamo gli autisti non abbiamo le auto
maggio abbiamo le sedi di rappresentanza
in tantissime città cosa che possono
sembrare assurdo ma che esistono e che
costano moltissimo e soprattutto non
abbiamo l'idea che il giornalista nel
2015 possa limitarsi a scrivere
l'articolo e non ha anche se per
ritoccare una foto sempre toccare un
video se per pubblicare un contenuto se
altri social network con competenza
saper ottimizzare un articolo perché sia
facilmente trovabile sui motori di
ricerca
queste cinque regole si riassumono un po
in una se ne sono molte altre ma si
riassumono in una frase che è un po il
nostro mantra quello che cerchiamo di
far sempre cerchiamo di fare le cose
bene
vi sembrerà banale ma provate a
immaginare di applicarlo nel vostro
settore professionale qualunque sia e
capirete che tipo di approccio e di
risultati rivoluzionari può ottenere la
semplice decisione di cominciare a fare
le cose bene
con questo successo il risultato è che
dopo cinque anni e mezzo il nostro
giornale ancora non era scontato che
fosse un cuore non solo sopravvissuto è
cresciuto moltissimo adesso siamo siamo
parecchi continuiamo a fare questo
lavoro continua a vivere a milano senza
lamentarmi ma e mi è capitato anche in
questi anni più volte ritornare a roma
vi ricorderete la città da cui era
cominciato tutto quella notte
una di queste volte ci sono tornato
perché dovevo sostenere l'esame da
giornalista perché per entrare
nell'ordine dei giornalisti che
sostenere un esame
e allora il giorno prima di arrivare a
roma ho aperto il mio computer e ho
cercato un albergo da prenotare pensato
di prendere un albergo nei pressi della
stazione perché potesse essere più
comodo poi spostarmi il giorno dopo
sono arrivato a roma sono arrivati in
albergo sono entrato nella hall e ho
avuto una sensazione di déjà vu mi sono
sentito ho pensato che quel posto mi era
familiare
ci ho pensato un attimo ho capito che
quello albergo in cui era entrato era
uno degli alberghi in cui era entrato
quella famosa notte quando ero disperato
cerca volevano essere internet risposta
in quella zona libera ed era appena
cominciato a fare quel mestiere
il fatto di tornarci per sostenere
l'esame mi è sembrata una chiusura del
cerchio così letteraria è così romantica
che dal punto vista personale mi ha
fatto dire beh insomma ogni tanto i
sogni si realizzano è stato molto bello
ma mi ha insegnato qualcosa anche dal
punto di vista generale ed è questo che
volevo condividere con voi oggi mi ha
fatto capire che per realizzare i propri
sogni per cambiare le cose
non è necessario sempre per forza essere
dei geni visionari essere steve jobs
essere albert einstein
anzi quel pensiero pure diventata spesso
autoassolutorio perché ci permette di
perdonare la nostra pigrizia ci fa
passare sopra il nostro adeguarci al
minimo standard indispensabile a fare il
minimo indispensabile invece a volte per
realizzare i propri sogni per cambiare
le cose
quello che ho capito che basta
semplicemente decidere quello che ci
manca a volte semplicemente la decisione
di fare quello che sappiamo va fatto che
se spesso è semplicemente fare le cose
bene e fare le cose come sappiamo che
vadano fatte per pretendere di più da
noi stessi non adeguarsi al minimo non
adeguarsi al pensiero che si è sempre
fatto così
chi me lo fa fare non cercare
l'asticella più bassa che si trova in
circolazione ma cercare l'asticella più
alta alla quale a mirare alla quale
puntare
perdonatemi la solennità un po pomposa e
la cosa che sto per dirvi che quasi mi
imbarazza ma se c'è una cosa che io ho
capito da questa mia esperienza è che
quello che mi piace condividere con voi
e che qualsiasi cosa voi facciate in
qualsiasi settore lavoriate non c'è cosa
che potete fare subito a nessun costo
per migliorare la vostra vita e quindi
anche quella degli altri che decidere da
subito di cominciare a fare le cose bene
non altro modo
o quantomeno di provarci grazie